füht sich wie Vergewaltigung für mir ich
einfach erinner für alles überall ich
mich eigentlichber
terrorisier ich ein nie vergiss Problem
kontion es
bringt
minut
we und
konzestens
5% ADS od
ADHS
die
diagn wieder wie
vorher
gr
doch Diagnose
betof
die norme
in das sch ja er zweite bfüht wenn du
taglich wlich so viel Problem mit d h
dass du D es bring dass du Glück
bist dann musst überlegen okay K die
Diagnose
mit ja wie fest
sp
was machen wir
damit ichuch Flav comedi Instagram
ADS
funktioniert die
ganze die
nächor
fertig
sehr bekan
vor zerstreut und
abgelent
sa
maletb restaur schwarzes Kaffee
bestelltkt
das
verglichkeit
typischmptom sy z
impulsivit
und aber Chaos im
Kopf mit Challenge orientier min
orientierslosigkeit ist
fatal weiß nicht der
Flavio Set kreative a influenzer da
Industriequartier Wintertour
Büro
ja ja früer ja freut
mich Stress morgen ja ich Stress morgen
schwierig bis hier noch mal lauft und
der tagf und so ein aber ich bin besser
Word also früh jetzt Termin Verg also
dir aber soon der Struktur her und
Organisation
da Upgrade so wie wie das geschafft ja
ich hab einfach eine erinner für alles
überall also ich ich hab Alarm auf dem
Handy ich hab alles im Kalender ich ma
vorhnotiz ich tu mich eigentlich wie
selber terrorisieren dass ich einfach
nie vergissen wie der Stress immer
[Musik]
nochchpass oder verschlaf oder was immer
ich freue mich
so das einf Person so verwirt ist Verg
we normal oder ich jetzt wirkich so
Krankheit ist Problem für Symptom
s Diagnose wird aufgrund von ausführlich
klinisch
gestellt nicht
das
bin ich jetzt komisch od so
und Bad of hon so
ja wie so romantisieren extrem ja und
ich glaube aber wasags
passiert
Hitze
ja doch ich Jacke
[Gelächter]
der Flavia 13 Videos am lieb alle im W
das hftim
Konzentrieren gen
oder das super
gan
jaarm sem g verglichkeit da
Unterhose Unterhose frag nicht was
dasterhose
everyday das
ist vergiss nicht das ist nicht aber ich
bin F gegangen und dann hab ich
wahinlich dankt ich vergisse safe zum un
mitum für Tag von der Woche einfach un
ja
so ja
ja Vanille Cola für
Kauf Stativ und Wasser mit hol alles für
mit Pabel mit
Office das ist jetzt für die typisch
ad ja
sch
me aber
das so F krankhaf
vergkeit das
ist stell und was es ist und abstellen
und
ja Tools und trotzdem fl ADS in ganz
nimmt du warst nicht so D man so wie
meint ja dies ADS identität stiften so
wie meinst es
ja ich w einfach nicht so ir zu
zuäerschild machen was lustig ich jetzt
mitm oder aber wieso
der das nicht so allzut Vordergrund
stell ich R gern drüber über me üht und
so aber nicht dass ich das wie so zu me
Identität ma als als hauptfacette V V
wer ich bin
so ich ich z
Zusam zu Ausreden oder für so für so
einen riesen Teil V von me Person ich w
einfach es ist ein Teil von mir aber es
bin nur ich
so
ich hab Gefühl dass es einfach so eine
allgemeine fokusschwäche Konzentration
sondern das ein mega viel damit hat
[Applaus]
jetztull Ich habe mich gestern nach
Festival
50 me
verfah
okay verlor
sch vi ist die schlechte
orientier aber positiv betroffen wieer
Flavio
kreativ
vorbereitet
Ban das mega lustig das schlimm ich h
das wenn ich mich selber aufnehm und na
so ist so fun
undund kreative schaff ist für
Flavio we ADHS und ADS
betroffen sehr interessier extrem
intensiv
und also weiß
so
platzfühltemt es juckt mich gar ma ich
da und jetzt Moment
bin Flow
state so jetzt uners ell jetzt bin jetzt
bin ich genau dem
Punkt und das ist das ist wirk so das
beste Gefühl das wirklich bis paar Jahr
mitfang mit dem
kreativ Glück journalis
Reg typisch
fl
hyperfokus
Verlauf ich sortiere jetzt min Gedanke
der flau stellt sich die Frag wo unruhig
macht sie
Symptom vom M also
normalchaftit ad neurobiologische stög
ist im H git ungichwicht Verbot Stoffe
sch zu 0% genetisch
bedingt ganz
ehrlich agn bis
nicht
Amfang wieder
vergessen
Frage einfacher wenn ich w
wie
um eine was intensiv dit beschäftigge
ist der
Marker
[Musik]
premiereipi langstrumstück
im
[Gelächter]
ich ich glaub noch nicht so wichtig
und
ja ich bin letzte Sekunden Mensch und
das Stress memfang m oder Gefüh ja das
ist Problem last minute das ist
klassisches ADH
syptomip
Stück Parallele zwischen ihm und BiPi V
beim Kampf die
Freiheit
und
und GLB das tut
g das ma ich das ma ja das
dasmerarbeitet ja Selbständigkeit so
oderelbständig und 12 Jahre gchaff und
jetzt kann ich das wirklich zu vor
vorlich immer immer
schemaedfunden
Struktur im leob sie für
marking Mark immer Wied ADH Abt worden
offizielle Diagnose geht
nichtm exper ad offizielle Diagnose vor
ADH nach das Mar Lifestyle selbst
bestimmt schperieler und Coach
schafflag also
das lelau x nach y nach A oder aber ich
so dankt ja das aus glücklicher
wie ja hat das nicht
ein du einfach da W gemacht ADH hin oder
her
ja
ja wieso um beruhigen W ich weiß D ich
nicht absichtlich SP komm nicht
absichtlich ke ord nicht absichtlich l
verletz nicht absichtlich emotional
werde aber es passiert immer wieder dass
sie mus das passiert wchentlich taglich
und wenn ich mir dann bewusst bin der
hilft mir und ich weiß
D Problem sie
es für verliedensduck das heißt wenn du
tlich wöchentlich so viel Problem mit
dem H dass du dass es dir dus bringt
dass du n glücklich bist D du ST dann
musst Du überlegen okay K die diagnoseis
mit
mir ja du
das du ja
ja W bin ich was möchte ich was hab ich
für z was hab ich für Glaubensmuster in
mir wo m stüre wo m sag sie s machen und
je meh mit D bewusst wordde desto mehr
wirklich los und D rum g
N der Mark ist
Zug normal ja so viel Fragen das jetzt
wirk mega viel Input und viel W Gang wie
von mir
saberkennt mir zwiel
span da
auf bewunder für Mark
für genau die Strategie für sich
entwickelt sich glaub sehr gut kenn du
weiß was funktioniert and S aber wie Z
wie fest s sich
über so eine Diagnose od wie viel
Gewicht
mith
ichuch
dann
znout radikale Konsequenzen
Zen ja geschafft 20 Minuten spat aber
nicht zu
fahren B
ST
willkommen ja krass du da völlig also
da super paradi Paradies
ja krass ja dann ganz bewusst ab vom
Schuss unduche ist sie h sie macht ger
der Fans Talent The Voice of Germany mit
ich bin ein R ich le auf der Bühne ich
le es vor der
Kamera kan ich einfach ja irgendwie das
das ist das ist voll Element und das kan
natürlich B
vololl t hab soes hallo geh
Schatz Partner wie lange s
schon Z Jahre
jetzt also was mir mit mir keelernt b b
b ist wie für z Jahre
eigentlich viel intens Intensivität ja
ja ja gut das ist sowieso mit mir
langig nicht ne ich geseh persönlich seh
ich Filme
positiv Aspekt eigentlich V ihrem ADS
Hirn wo sie hat neurodivergent
odert einfach es ist ein andere Art von
ten diversere Art von denk
genau Norm aber das ist ja einfach ab V
der Norm
und ich B und ich du bist genau Mitte
für mich und
mich ich
bin
beim bra im 100%ztig fus geht
für wenn ich jetzt spezifisch müsst
machen kompliziertes Rezept der W
schwierig aber Kürbis ich ma jetzt
kürbisürbis schen und das ist das ist
kein Stress
dann
kindergärtnerinchaff
nicht ich
die norme in press in
Zwang dass mich das unglaublich viel
Energie kostet h und will ich es aber so
gut
gelernt mich ich selber n gemerkt wie
sehr
michstrengtel Energie mich das kostet
und das hat Schluss ja er und
zweiteführt
so machen jetzt macht die 40jig
umschulig zwachsen bildnerin was n Pass
und
[Musik]
seting also mE Freund muss immer la wenn
ich miching find das
wieendwi das sind
einfachge
[Applaus]
kann ich z Partner me mich so
unterstützt seid
Schatz Versuch noch Versuch
noch wirklich 100% alles
geh damit ich vielleicht ein doch ein
nur noch
singe alles andere ist immer so trostpr
für mich das war beste für d ad es ist
einach ADHS nur ein Vorteil es gibt kein
Nachteil be der Musik und ich bin kan
den gefühlt ganz mich selber sie und
fühl mich fühl mich
einfach ja null falsch hey a zi ja mer
viel mal Danke Danke
dir ja das wünsche dir auch und
gutü
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nicht ganz Gesellschaft
passen Granze ich Ken es die abschweifen
Gedanken und Ideen es ist immer wieder
ABW ausbrechen oder
abassen schwierig
ma Interview vorbereit schn kann nicht
konzentrieren
und
abgelenkt
aber ja es ist Hal wie es ist und ich
hab auch gewnt das D es daz gehört und
die weiß V
mit vertrau duffah dass es ja wieder and
ist wieder
100% duf fokussiert B to mir Arbe
verlier das ein aus vergissen was nacher
sehr schön und
intensiv sch vi aber vielleicht nicht
immer gleich stätig oder gleiche
stabil und
ja es gab das Medikament wo das
konzentrationsdefizit ausglich Z
italin mitm inklusive ich momentan keine
Medikament mir
stimulanzber W Medikament Strategie od W
Kombination löig mit dem ADHS expert
bespreche wenn ist der italin
abcht stimulanen alsofenidat also
Ritalin oder andere
stimulanen können sehr sehr gut helfen
das ganze so einfacher zu machen also
ich beschre das so wie ähm äh eine
Krücke man konnte sagen die mir hilft im
Alltag so vorwärts zu kommen viele
Betroffene sagen das ist wie ein ich
habe wie dann wie ein
Kanal also etwas so also Scheuklappen
sag sag sagen viele Leute aber im
positiven Sinne dass ich denke ich kann
jetzt einfach mich auf irgendetwas
konzentrieren und da fällt einfach der
Leidensdruck Weg in vielen Fällen hilft
es extrem weil man nicht vergessen darf
dass es ein Geburtsgebrechen ist also es
ist nicht irgendwie ich bin nicht faul
oder unkonzentriert weil ich einfach gar
keine Lust habe sondern es wirklich
auch ein Geburtsgebrechen und was
medikamentös neurophysiologisch so
korrigiert werden kann Medikament s
Wachs die richti
expert aber was der franis GR mach m
wach es geht ums akzeptier von ang
funktionier und Emanzipation unsere wel
unsere Welt ist linear das bedeutet ich
muss pünktlich sein ich muss meine ich
habe deadlines ich muss meine Rechnung
zahlen ich muss irgendwie pünktlich bei
der Arbeit sein ich muss mich
organisieren und die Emanzipation ist
dass man sagt ich ich seid immer
funktioniere ich
anders also ich habe Mühe ich zahle
meine Rechnung im letzten Moment oder
ich komme immer zu spät oder
beim Studium habe ich sehr viel
improvisiert bei der Arbeit auch in
meiner meine Partnerschaft ist so
geprägt von auf und ab so aber ich
emanzipiere mich dass ich denke ich bin
kein schlechter
Mensch das ist okay bis bald
danke das mit der Emanzipation ist schö
Gedanke dann mit nach dem Gesprach frage
ich aber wen der ledensdruck so h ist
wie den Mark auf der war der Medikament
nicht Chance ich w das mit dem
besprechen der Mark
letff die lineare
Gesellschaft
funktionier wie die lineare
Gesellschaft sag
jaa das überle ich bin
Mensch wo möcht sich saber sie und möcht
Struktur finden oder
Verhaltensform wie mit miruber klar und
solange
das
Verdeck das wieder oder also ich kan zu
mir solange das n Angst V
Abhängigkeit ja für mich es ganz klar V
Abhängigkeit wenn ich weiß für nicht mit
Abit wenn wenn ich weiß ich muss das
Konsumieren damit ich normal B
Gesellschaft wie mit der abhängigit
abhängig von de Medikament damit Norm s
nicht s
ST Form finden wie wie oder
oder und D nimmt natürlich Stress ab den
nimmt unglücklich sie ab
negativefü
impulsivit mer viel ja
Sch
gutü
für Mark ist es
ZK die Tri die Kraft das beruhiget und
der gedankke mach
für St wie vor mit W ADH s Toleranz der
Gesellschaft mus
mit
sag SP ver
die
gemeinschaftsgedke passen undich immer
wieder Balanceakt wie viel sch möglich
passenis wo m mega beschäftigge schon
lang sowieso ich elers sie immer noch so
eine Big Deal
mit wo aufut Angers ist
soamhautell oder so kte sagen hey Mensch
ist Mensch es geht verschiedene sortte
geh dir geh dir und das ist schöns das
wünscht mich wie geht's dir was ist du
System oder schon Mass schon
diefüt kom R drüber verz wie es Dir geht
hier oder hier hat andere Filme zu de
Thema
[Musik]
verlinkt